in this video we're going to dig a
little bit into the idea of what it
means to be a monopoly
and so to help us appreciate that let's
think about the spectrum on which firms
can be
so this is going to be my spectrum right
over here
now at the left end we can imagine this
idealized perfect competition
perfect
competition
and we've talked about that in other
videos but just as a review this is
where you have many firms
this is where
they are selling an undifferentiated
product
or service
undifferentiated
undifferentiated product
the firms over here they have no
barriers to entry or exit so no
barriers
to entry
or exit
these firms we've talked about in other
videos they need to be price takers why
do they need to be price takers well
whatever the market price is
since no one cares which of these firms
which of these many firms they get the
product from none of those firms can
really set their own price if they were
to go above the market price well then
no one will buy from them and so they
will just be price
price takers
and other things that we assume about
perfect competition is that all of the
actors in the market both the buyers the
many buyers and the many sellers they
all know what what the transactions are
going on for they know who's selling to
whom for what amount now the other
extreme
this is where we have the monopoly
monopoly
here instead of many firms selling or
many firms producing you have exactly
one firm
producing instead of an undifferentiated
product well it's differentiated because
it's the only firm
instead of no barriers to entry exit
here we're at the exact opposite so you
could say insurmountable insurmountable
mountable i'll just abbreviate it
barriers
especially to enter
and instead of being a price taker you
are a price setter
price setter you're the only player
you're the only actor who is selling
anything so you can decide what price to
sell it at
now perfect competition as i talked
about it's a bit of a theoretical idea
it's hard to say any market that is
absolutely perfect but we can imagine
markets that are on this spectrum some
closer to perfect competition some
closer to a monopoly things that i can
imagine that are closer to perfect
competition might be let's say
agriculture
or a certain type of agriculture let's
say you're buying pistachios and you
might be most people are indifferent as
to where their pistachios come from
although some people might beg to differ
that certain types of pistachios are
better than others but for the most part
that'd be closer to perfect competition
there will be just a price in the market
for pistachios if someone wants to grow
pistachios i'm not familiar with what it
takes to grow pistachios and i apologize
to any offense to any pistachio growers
out there but maybe they can just get
enough land and there's very close to
low barriers to entry and they can start
producing pistachios as i mentioned many
would perceive it as undifferentiated
and there might be many firms in say the
pistachio market i actually don't know
if that's the case but let's just assume
if that were the case it would be closer
to perfect competition
now a monopoly you can imagine things
like
things that take a lot of infrastructure
in order to do that service so i can
imagine things like
over here close to monopoly or at
monopoly you can imagine things like
utilities providers
utilities
where it's hard for multiple people to
run
power lines to the various houses
you can imagine things like this telecom
telecom
providers might be close although in
most geographies you have more than one
telecom providers although in some parts
of the world you're getting pretty close
to one because once again there's very
very very high barriers to entering
either one of those you got to launch
satellites and and put up and put cable
under the the ground and dig up roads
and whatever and so you could get closer
and closer to this notion of
maybe there's one firm if you're in a
situation like telecom in a lot of the
places where you have only a handful of
firms that's known as an oligopoly but
let's just think about the extreme when
you're in a monopoly situation
and so the next few videos we're going
to dive a little bit deeper into what it
means to be a monopoly and what is the
rational
quantity for a profit maximizing
monopolistic firm to actually produce
and what would be their economic profit